12 est à présent face à la première
[Musique]
intégrer le monde l'expression résume
assez bien l'oeuvre et la pensée de
notre invité du jour on écrivait célèbre
il situe sa littérature entre l'oral et
l'écrit depuis une quarantaine d'années
il a publié une cinquantaine d'oeuvres
de toute nature bandes dessinées romans
poèmes préface textes politiques pièce
de théâtre à l'occasion de la parution
ces jours ci aux éditions du seuil de
son dernier essai le compteur la nuit et
le panier et pour mieux lui fait tant
parler de lui ce qu'il n'aime guère
nous recevons le lauréat du prix
goncourt obtenu en 1992 pour son
époustouflant roman texaco vous l'aurez
reconnu madame monsieur bonjour patrick
chamoiseau
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je sais que vous êtes très
occupé ces jours ci comme tous les jours
d'ailleurs mais merci de ces quelques
minutes passées avec les internautes et
les auditrices et les auditeurs de
marthe n'est que la première de notre
émission face à la première en ce
dimanche 11 avril 2021
c'est l'émission politique hebdomadaire
de la rédaction de notre rédaction
réalisé aujourd'hui par jean-louis bongo
et paul éric doucet face à la première
[Musique]
à la patrick chamoiseau faisons l'injure
de croire que vous êtes complètement
inconnu vous êtes né en décembre 1953 à
fort-de-france veuillez compléter votre
fiche d'identité s'il vous plaît oui ma
fiche d'identité elle est assez simple
je suis né à fort de france à la wii
françois ragot là où il est si rien donc
tout l'univers que je décris dans mes
romans entre le marché aux légumes le
marché aux poissons le pont guidon donc
en dalles et cetera c'est vraiment la
période en france et c'est vrai que chez
un créateur la période à l'enfance et la
période imprégnation et c'est vrai que
lorsque j'ai commencé à écrire pendant
longtemps j'ai essayé de faire ce qui se
faisait à l'époque je commence à écrire
dès l'âge de 12 ans et à l'époque on
était plus